how did it feel out there that's great
do you think you want to change you
think you want to do it because it was
perfect better that's all we always want
to baby you do it better than that lots
of ways feel the energy out there oh
yeah you know anytime Luke Bryan's
cheering for me uh there's a lot of
energy what did Luke do he was right
pants he came up to the stage and rubbed
my pants really we not see that that's
it's on film I'm sure oh my god now I'm
gonna have to go look at that your claim
to fame molested by Luke Bryan on you
didn't see as he had picked this nose
right before I know was the best thing
about coming off with and what did you
enjoy the most about the the show so far
that's not a bad thing is it
no I mean the brothers I was born
America we're really good yeah Miranda's
thing was really good everybody's been
really good how you guys gonna celebrate
tonight
tequila definitely tequila me going up a
Danish a right yeah for sure sure
more tequila oh wait what does that mean
you guys have been bad boys in Vegas yes
who's had the most aquila right now I'm
not sure do somebody take take the edge
off he keeps passing down the edge off
before the show right well
congratulations
have a lot of fun tonight okay so his
leg and I said I go I got a touch I know
I might've robbed him of high quality TV
time but damn it I just got I got caught
up and I just had to just feel it it's
literally in the middle of the
performance so the back story is two
years it was it two or three years ago
years ago they rewrote lyric no there's
no the line is can't keep the ground
from second man Brian from change and
they did that live and I did a cartwheel
backstage it was hey let's bet that was
more fun than my career just pay back
basically so there's shenanigan forever
anytime year-round there on yeah Larry
got a verified it was a linear time only
team well the highlight of the evening
look rubbing your legs people across
America wish they had that